ha sido muy emotivas la monarca de 96
años apareció sonriente y completamente
feliz en dos oportunidades desde el
balcón del palacio de buckingham una
imagen que nos veíamos hace casi tres
años incluso antes de la pandemia del
hobbit 19 la reina apareció como les
comento en dos oportunidades para
saludar a las miles y miles de personas
que se congregaron aquí en las afueras
del palacio de bukingham desde las
primeras horas de esta mañana para poder
presenciar este momento histórico pero
algunas incluso arribaron a la noche
para poder estar en este lugar como les
digo en dos oportunidades la primera
para saludar a las tropas que partieron
desde ese lugar que ustedes ven a mis
espaldas y la segunda para presenciar
esos seis minutos de la revista militar
impresionante con la que se celebraron
sus 70 años en el trono pero el show se
lo robó definitivamente el bisnieto de
la reina el príncipe louis de 4 años el
hijo menor de los duques de cambridge
kate y william que durante la revista
militar el niño sonreía pero también por
el ruido de los aviones se tapaba los
oídos y sacaba la lengua también lo hizo
la princesa charlotte así que los niños
fueron también los protagonistas la
reina a lució un vestido azul pálido con
un sombrero una fotografía que un
vestido que usó para la fotografía
oficial con el que se marcan estos 70
años de su reinado